Matthew Joseph and the fans will let
you know when he's got the puck back
for daru back for Joseph back for
JW and a backhand shot get stopped
by L crossing the line with r mus that
went off for Bello back out front po one
after yeah puck lead pass for valeno blocker to
Side by coraco on the wing for Drake paperson
that just went wide granstrom able to
keep it in for Ottawa the defenseman
from Sweden number 26 right in the slot and
kicked Away by lion knock to the corner for
MATA gave it away the chuck on the steel
and he was instrumental in their comeback
over Nashville loose in front picked up by
berson giving the Red Wings 10 double digits
goal scores this season it's seven all last
year should have a few more before too long
including valeno who's got nine scores cpra
great shot what a b it felt it [Applause]
happened and it's the buck retrieved by
Baleno and this a long distance pass and
a one-time it's a rare happening but play
like this happens and you score and I'm
sure the goal tender is not going to be happy
with himself the pass takes a long time to get
there but with a great shot that up high with
it to Brink it the former Ottawa senator from
a season ago here's lur and up oh it hit
him right in the head oh what's this shabat
got it ahead knocked out of the air by spitza
with a good feed in and a good stop there off
Chan up for Dominic kubalik the terle rather into
the slot it goes for br oh my what a save cleared
around and able to keep it in and Shane gos
is beare for Dylan lar and then he was checked
knocked off his stick by Parker Kelly of all
people you made a mistake this thing make it
up that's exactly your point Detroit number
27 Michael so power play here for Ottawa and
a good save there by lion from Point Blank Range
it's their first shot on their two power plays
so far tonight didn't have one in the first
quad daroo with it Chuck tried to tip it in
front Norris will chase he'll get there before
Shabbat he didn't try any of this stuff in the
first Power Play Going Down Low of it jeru slot
pin save lion without a stick is confer in front
for kachak K garu he has it now top of the right
Circle wrist shot that went [Applause] wide his
brother Pierre Olivier is in Pittsburgh brought
in by Lucas Raymond turning away from Shabbat
finds wman with that blast and a good right pad
save fiser took his man out kept it alive for Ras
M then fiser hit Norris and H able to recover
took a shot and a save made olly in deep with
it one of the 10 double digigit goal scores in
the Red Wings lineup Paul got checked by Pinto
back in front and Greg couldn't bury that Feen
Ryan from Vegas sign in trade teraso REM missed
a wide open net at the other end in the first
along with Ridley Greg aleno escaped a hard
hit as Mark casik hit him try to get a piece
of him scores cast look in front may have got
a piece of that to tip it home his third game
the past four for the Phoenix born kid yes he
did get a piece of it nobody home and this got
going way wide than net and look at that yeah
goalie can only hope it hits him and we got a
tie game because of it missed a lot of time to
injury this season six weeks from the beginning
of November the breakup did well to get in front
of jaru allowing wman to get it to Larin one shot
both stopped by Corell on a second try too broken
stick for jaru when jaru went to Ottawa yes it's
home for him he said he came to Ottawa to win
he thought the rebuild would be ahead of where
they are now there's a shot by Kelly stopped by
lion shot there by Zu hit his own man in front
friendly fire then chicken with a shot going
wide as lion came over Tyler cevin he's a
good young player in the American Hockey
League a left shot defenseman giving up
here Wallman just missed far aside Alex der
Brink faab left there valeno now tried to
go to spraw out of the box comes kachuck
and he's in the clear Brady kachuck
scores out of the box to the back of
the net it's 2-1 Ottawa Edmonton oers all
over again used to happen with them all the
time Detroit head possession there it was a
a defensive play and a blowing Tire by cider
yep that blocked the shot and deflected it out to
Santa right oh my goodness on Instagram cuz I know
Mick you're all over that oh yeah yeahhuh here's
strong with a good move strong and reaching out
Corella to hold on to it short side did strong
you don't see him on the back hand very much he
uses a very very stiff [Music] [Applause] stick
and again he's got it there for lin to gos Bear
Down Low it goes oh and to Brink it Stone by
Corpus solo he bounced once it hit to Brink
it stick and he really didn't have a whole lot
of options cleared but kept in by chicker and
a save made off tou by the overtime goal in
Sweden and that is a great a scoring chance
in matam moved at coner Lin out of the corner
up high with it the shot he scores Dylan lurin
22 [Music] [Applause] [Music] and the point
streak hits a [Applause] [Music] dozen so
fiser still on the ice after coming out
on the penalty it was almost a two-on-one
almost a mirror image of Brady kachuck goal
it made it two to one in the second period
but Ottawa nullified that two onone and fiser
in front of the net as lens shot finds a hole
and ties this game with 845 to go on for Ridley
Greg one-on-one with gos Fair save made by lion
back in front Lon wasn't sure where it
was two two tie Ottawa came very close
here off Fisher and just
wide remember it was stza with
the late winner on ryr in Sweden
against Detroit Shabbat with pinto pass to him he
scores Shane Pinto in his sixth game gets his
second goal and Ottawa wins it 3 [Applause] to2
really Detroit never got possession as I could
see and a perfect deflection du Bret came back
on the play I mean all the way from Center up
but what a beautiful setup by Thomas Shabbat I
mean and and he had to reach forward Pinto to
deflect it if he doesn't do that the Puck's in
front of him and I don't know right at
this point in time for the time on ice
for shabot but I'm guessing it's close to
30 minutes and chech about 30 43 3043 go
3043 wow Ottawa came to play and the out chance
Detroit certainly by tonight uh by quite a bit